[Musique]
les professionnels de santé du chu de
belles pierres reçoivent la ministre de
la santé
un moment important car cet
établissement impressionne par ses
chiffres deux cent cinquante mille
consultations par an cent dix sept mille
passages aux urgences ou encore six
mille professionnels bien la ministre
arrive avec des bonnes nouvelles
l'état accompagne ce chu de manière
importante c'est un soutien très
important entre 30 et 40 % du chemin et
accompli par greta maintenant pour
trouver le chemin de l'équilibré
budgétaire qui est une condition sine
qua none pour avoir un chu pérenne qui
offre des soins de qualité à la
population réunionnaise qui soit
innovant qui puisse faire des
investissements qu'ils puissent garder
c'est encore c'est à nous aux
hospitaliers de faire le reste du chemin
réunion de travail avec toutes les
forces en présence avec les syndicats le
programme de la ministre est dense une
ministre de la santé également de la
solidarité un élément important car le
département est en première ligne je
trouve qu à partir de l écoute
elle va certainement nous apporter des
solutions et encore une fois qui ne
demande pas forcément des solutions
budgétaires mais parfois c'est ne
serait-ce que le travailler ensemble
nous sommes sur un petit territoire nous
département nous avons à prendre en
charge les problèmes de l'enfance et
bien travaillé avec les services de
l'état en matière de politique de santé
c'est important
l'inauguration du nouveau bâtiment de
soins critiques fait partie de la visite
un projet né suite à la crise du
chikungunya de 2006 ce site répond
maintenant à ce type de situation on est
exposé du jour au lendemain parfois à
des nécessités des recueils de 68 ch et
de façon aiguë mais qui de fait le
justifient pas d'avoir une activité à
temps plein toute l'année pour mettre un
projet en entier pour soi plutôt nos
véhicules pour je pense que mettre en
valeur
le parcours coordonné ça participe à
l'efficience et à la qualité des soins
qu'on donne est donc il faut
impérativement qu'on arrive à valoriser
la coordination médicale ou paramédicale
qu'on arrive à valoriser des parcours de
soins
réfléchis organisé et ça fait partie de
l'efficience qui sauvera notre système
de santé sur le long terme
tous les échelons de la santé qui
répondraient collectivement afin de
rendre efficient l'offre de soins voilà
l'un des enjeux d'avenir
[Musique]